[Music]
so in certain types of engineering
practices there's this idea that the
computer and mathematics itself are sort
of a and culture right that they just
exist in in their own technical and
formal world well every computer system
is built within the social and
historical context of its time I coined
the term that has no media to describe a
sense that computational media can be
used to express rich mental imagery so
in literary arts we have rich worlds
that are constructed rich imaginative
worlds that people can explore and enter
at the same time other other art forms
have really engaged the human condition
and have really thought about issues of
ideology how do you change ideology how
do you construct ideology through
constructing meaning and media
[Music]
well fantazmo gets out both of those
kind of concerns because anta's mada in
cognitive science has been used to
describe mental images and in literary
arts we've used the term that has more
to describe the kind of social illusions
that exist that we all are somehow
submit to you could say in a nutshell we
want to be able to distinguish users
look at the way stickers built in the
systems and do better and then also to
be able to empower users to more
expressively herself represent mas
undersea is an interactive narrative
artwork or kind of interactive poetic AI
based artwork in which you have a
character that's falling further and
further under the sea
well I'm falling into the sea as a kind
of metaphor for everyday life
well as a character moves for that space
they have a choice of different kind of
actions to undertake each of those
choices is imbued with certain kind of
emotional tone or emotional power so the
poetry is generated based on it AI
algorithm built into a system called Rio
that I created and that poetry has a
different emotional disposition based on
the actions that the person has taken no
matter what medium we're dealing with
whether it's the gaming or social media
we're interested in using the power of
the medium to convey meaning differently
each time to help people to become more
empowered and critically aware of the
social cultural issues that they're
engaged
[Music]
devourer bullying and striving morning
diner in the morning and Nancy an aroma
I get up from my work desk often if I
want to
[Music]
[Music]
because take a step back
using its wisdom that comes from the
humanities and from the arts and then
say help me do this America
[Music]